gracias
[Aplausos]
a todos todos ustedes
en este día que indudablemente es
histórico
[Aplausos]
es historia
lo que estamos escribiendo en este
momento
una historia nueva
para colombia para américa latina
para el mundo
[Música]
una historia nueva
porque indudablemente
aquí lo que ha ocurrido hoy
con estos 11 millones de lectoras y
electores que votaron y nos trajeron a
esta tarima y al gobierno de colombia es
un cambio
aquí
lo que viene es un cambio de verdad
o un cambio real
en ello
comprometemos
la existencia a la vida misma
no vamos a traicionar ese electorado que
lo que le ha gritado
al país
precisamente a la historia es que a
partir de hoy
colombia cambia
colombia es otra
un cambio real que nos conduce a algunas
de las de los planteamientos
que habíamos hecho en estas plazas
públicas
la política del amor
no es un cambio para vengarnos
no es un cambio para construir más odios
no es un cambio para profundizar el
sectarismo en la sociedad colombiana
nuestros padres nuestros abuelos en su
propia vida nos enseñaron que significa
el sectarismo que significa el odio en
la historia de colombia el cambio
consiste precisamente
en dejar el odio atrás
el cambio consiste precisamente
en dejar los sectarismos atrás
la selección es más o menos
mostraron dos colombias
cercanas en términos de votos
nosotros queremos que colombia en medio
de su diversidad sea una colombia no dos
colombias
de para que sea una colombia
en esa enorme diversidad multicolor que
somos
necesitamos del amor
entendida la política del amor como una
política del entendimiento
como una política del diálogo como una
política de comprendernos los unos a los
otros
el cambio
también significa
la bienvenida a la esperanza
la posibilidad de abrir un futuro
el cambio significa
abrir las oportunidades para todos y
todas las colombianas
la esperanza
el cambio significa
que esa esperanza puede hacer y llenar
todos los rincones del territorio
nacional
que la esperanza reine en el corazón el
cambio significa que llegó el gobierno
de la esperanza
[Aplausos]
por eso tengo que agradecerles
primero a ustedes
las miles y miles de personas
que a lo largo y ancho del país durante
días durante meses bajo el sol bajo la
lluvia fueron a seducir el voto
fueron a dialogar con los otros y con
las otras le tendieron la mano
aquel que no creía todavía
aquella que era escéptica que pudieron
establecer los puentes y ahí cómo se
construye la política del amor para
construir una mayoría
una mayoría que sin ustedes no hubiera
sido posible
[Música]
les agradezco
[Aplausos]
ahora son ustedes la fuerza del cambio
la fuerza del amor la fuerza de la
esperanza
quiero agradecerle
a mi mamá que no está aquí con nosotros
exiliada se tuvo que ir
aclara
a mi padre aquí presente que cogió las
banderas
para luchar
a mis hijos hijas
[Música]
algunas aquí
[Aplausos]
antonella ni con su esposa sofía
[Música]
está andrea está andrés y está el otro
nicolás en otras partes del mundo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
quiero agradecerle a veronica
que me ha aguantado
me ha aguantado durante años
que ha logrado un espacio de liderazgo
propio
[Aplausos]
y quiero agradecer la francia
con todo lo que
eso significa
para el pueblo colombiano
[Aplausos]
gracias a todo ese esfuerzo
gracias a esa enorme fuerza que viene de
antaño que viene de atrás de
generaciones que ya no están con
nosotros
somos parte apenas de un acumulado de
una resistencia que ya tiene cinco
siglos diría francia
que somos la sumatoria de la resistencia
de colombia que hemos congregado
no solo ese pasado de luchas
de resistencias de rebeldías
indudablemente de rebeldías contra la
injusticia
de rebeldías contra un mundo que no
debería ser de rebeldías contra la
discriminación de rebeldías contra la
desigualdad
cuánta gente que aquí no nos acompaña
hoy
cuanta gente
que desapareció por los caminos de
colombia y no se encuentran
decenas de miles
cuanta gente que murió
cuanta gente que está presa hoy en estos
momentos
cuántos jóvenes encadenados
esposados
tratados como bandoleros
simplemente
porque tenían esperanza
simplemente porque tenían amor
yo le solicito
al fiscal general de la nación
que libere a nuestra juventud
liberen a los jóvenes
[Aplausos]
yo le solicito
a la procuradora general de la nación
que restituyen sus puestos a los
alcaldes de elección popular
[Aplausos]
ya no es
el momento de los odios
este gobierno que es va a iniciar el 7
de agosto
es un gobierno de la vida
es el gobierno que quiere construir a
colombia como una potencia mundial de la
vida
y si queremos
[Aplausos]
sintetizar quizás entre frases
en qué consiste un gobierno de la vida
yo diría
primero en la paz
segundo en la justicia social
tercero
en la justicia ambiental
[Aplausos]
gracias antanas
la paz
como eje de un gobierno de la vida la
paz
no tendría razón el cambio
no tendría razón el amor no tendría
razón la esperanza no tendría razón este
esfuerzo mayúsculo que hoy se sintetiza
en las urnas no tendría sentido un
gobierno de la vida si no llevamos a la
sociedad colombiana a la paz
objetivo central
qué significa poder hacer la paz
significa que los 10 millones y pico de
electores de rodolfo hernández son
bienvenidos en este gobierno
[Aplausos]
significa
que rodolfo hernández
que hizo una campaña interesante
puede dialogar con nosotros cuando
quiera
significa
que no vamos
a partir de este gobierno a utilizar el
poder
en función de destruir al oponente
significa
[Aplausos]
que nos perdonamos
significa que la oposición
que tendremos
me disculpa la voz de siete meses de
desgaste
significa
que esa posición
bajo los liderazgos que quieran
sea el de uribe sea el de federico o sea
el de rodolfo sea el de todos juntos sea
el que quieran será siempre bienvenida
en el palacio de nariño para dialogar
sobre los problemas de colombia
[Aplausos]
porque el clima político que nos ha
acompañado en este siglo
[Aplausos]
el clima político
que nos ha acompañado en este siglo que
ha sido de odios de confrontaciones
literalmente a muerte de persecuciones
de aislamientos
hoy no puede seguir así
habrá oposición indudablemente y quizá
férrea y quizás tenaz y quizás no lo
entenderemos muchas veces pero de este
gobierno que se inicia nunca habrá
persecución política ni persecución
jurídica
sólo habrá
respeto y diálogo es así como podremos
construir lo que hace unos días llamamos
el gran acuerdo nacional
[Música]
ya se comenzó a construir entre 11
millones de colombianos y de colombianas
pero tiene que ser entre 50 millones
tiene que ser con toda la sociedad
colombiana
el gran acuerdo nacional
tiene que comenzar a construirse a
partir del diálogo regional
vinculante
vinculante significa que lo que se
decida regionalmente para acabar los
conflictos violentos para construir la
prosperidad
regional
se vuelve normal se vuelve obligatorio
se cumple diálogos regionales que nos
permitan mirar el conflicto en su
especificidad histórica
en su especificidad
regional
en esos
diálogos regionales en esas regiones
debe llegar la diversidad de colombia no
simplemente quien ha levantado armas
sino esa mayoría silenciosa
de campesinos de indígenas de mujeres de
jóvenes
sobre la base de los diálogos regionales
poder construir
las reformas que necesita colombia para
poder convivir en paz
[Aplausos]
no es
extraño
que en esos 11 millones de votos que nos
han dado el triunfo
la mayoría sean de jóvenes
y de mujeres
[Aplausos]
[Música]
una marea juvenil
decidió hoy tomarse las urnas
una marea femenina
decidió hoy
tomarse las urnas
[Aplausos]
el acuerdo nacional por tanto tiene que
ver con reformas que necesitan y han
gritado hoy las juventudes y las mujeres
de colombia tiene que ver
con los derechos fundamentales que no
pueden ser más letra muerta en la
constitución sino que tienen que ser la
vida cotidiana la existencia real la
garantía plena de una constitución viva
que se pueda
y palpar que se pueda vivir todos los
días una constitución viva en la
plenitud de los derechos de la gente si
me preguntan para qué es un acuerdo
nacional yo diría para construir los
máximos consensos que nos permitan las
reformas que hagan que la vida de la
familia pueda ser una vida mejor que
allí el viejo y la vieja puedan tener
una pensión
que allí
el joven
las jóvenes puedan tener una universidad
que allí
el niño y la niña
puedan tener la leche y el pan y la
carne no sea un artículo del hongo que
allí la familia pueda construirse más
sólida más fuerte más poderosa porque
sus derechos
fundamentales como personas humanas se
pueden garantizar
se pueden cumplir si me lo permiten el
gran acuerdo nacional es para construir
la paz y la paz no es más que la
garantía de los derechos de la gente
la paz
es que la sociedad colombiana tenga
oportunidades la paz es que alguien como
yo pueda ser presidente o alguien como
francia pueda ser vicepresidenta
la paz
es que dejemos de matarnos los unos a
los otros
desde el gobierno que se iniciará el 7
de agosto
comenzará la paz integral en colombia
a partir primero
del gran diálogo nacional entre la
sociedad colombiana todas y en segundo
lugar a partir
de lograr que las armas dejen de
disparar que las armas dejen de usarse
que las armas dejen de existir por fuera
del estado colombiano no es matarnos los
unos a los otros es amarnos los unos a
los otros
[Aplausos]
un gobierno
de la vida por tanto no sólo es la paz
es la justicia social
en estas campañas venían gritándonos una
y otra vez
construyendo la contracampaña quizás a
partir de las mentiras y del miedo que
íbamos a expropiar los bienes de los
colombianos que íbamos
a destruir la propiedad privada pues
bien de manera franca aquí les diría lo
siguiente
nosotros vamos a desarrollar el
capitalismo en colombia
[Aplausos]
no porque lo adoremos
sino porque tenemos primero que superar
la premodernidad en colombia' el
feudalismo en colombia
los nuevos esclavismo la nueva
esclavitud
tenemos que superar
mentalidades atípicas
atávicas ligadas allá a ese mundo de
siervos a ese mundo de esclavos que
tenía como contraparte los señores y los
dueños esclavistas tenemos que construir
una democracia y esa democracia la vamos
a construir a partir de permitir que
exista un pluralismo de conciencias un
pluralismo ideológico
un pluralismo de colores un pluralismo
económico
el pluralismo económico significa
superar las viejas esclavitud es los
viejos feudalismos poder tener una
tierra que se llene de alimentos
cultivados
tener
un espacio para las comunidades
indígenas para que se desarrolle su
autonomía su cultura tener una economía
popular que se pueda fortalecer
a través de la conectividad a través de
la educación a través del crédito barato
de ahí saldrán
formas del capitalismo sí ojalá
democrático
ojalá productivo ojalá no especulador de
ahí saldrán también nuevas formas de
relacionamiento de la humanidad a partir
de las nuevas tecnologías de ahí saldrá
una economía fuerte productiva por eso
queremos transitar de la vieja economía
extractivista
que mataba el agua y que mataba la vida
hacia una nueva economía productiva que
puede hacer crecer en toda colombia
puestos de trabajo producción que es la
base misma de la riqueza la riqueza
nacional
depende del trabajo si es el trabajo es
asalariado si ese trabajo es
independiente si ese trabajo es
solidario y cooperativo
si ese trabajo adquiere las nuevas
formas de la economía colaborativa
tendrá el respaldo del nuevo gobierno
porque sólo sobre la base
de crecer económicamente
de producir es que podremos entonces
también
redistribuir
no se puede redistribuir
sin producir
por tanto si queremos redistribuir para
que la sociedad todas sea más
igualitaria tenemos que producir
producir en el campo producir en la
industria producir en el turismo
producir sobre la base del conocimiento
que es cómo se produce en el siglo 21
producir
regulados
sin que se afecte la dignidad humana
producir
regulados de tal manera que no se afecte
la naturaleza que no se afecte el agua
que no se afecte el páramo
que no se afecte el pájaro
[Aplausos]
producir
respetando la naturaleza
que significa la justicia ambiental
y aquí
podríamos sintetizar
que es un gobierno de la vida
la paz
la justicia social
la justicia ambiental las madres que no
tengan que venir aquí a mostrar los
rostros de sus hijos asesinados
[Aplausos]
buenas noches para todos
al óvalo
el nombre de mi hijo dylan que es una
víctima más de este país el nombre de
todas las víctimas de los falsos
positivos nicolás neira yuri yuri neira
diego felipe becerra y todas aquellas
víctimas que hemos sido de este gobierno
y de los anteriores a su amigos por mi
hijo porque sigo justicia
venía presidente porque en usted está la
esperanza de todos nosotros de la
justicia en ustedes en esperanza en
nosotros los pobres de los necesitados
del negro del blanco del rico del pobre
en ustedes a la esperanza bienvenido a
colombia a nuestro país presidente
[Aplausos]
paz
justicia social
justicia ambiental el gobierno de la
vida
y aquí discúlpenme
ahora que hablamos de naturaleza
hacer un paréntesis
para hablar al mundo
queremos que colombia y será la
prioridad de la política diplomática se
coloque al frente en el mundo de la
lucha contra el cambio climático
la ciencia
nos ha dicho que como especie humana
podemos perecer en el corto plazo que la
vida en esta tierra hermosa puede
perecer en el corto plazo que las
dinámicas de acumulación que un mercado
desaforado que unos deseos de codicia y
ganancia desaforadas que un proceso de
consumo desaforado
está a punto de acabar con las bases
mismas de la existencia no nos lo dicen
las izquierdas no nos lo dicen las
derechas no lo dice la ciencia
si la ciencia no lo dice
toca actuar ya no somos uno de estos
países que emiten en enormes cantidades
el co2 y los gases efecto invernadero
pero estamos aquí al lado de una de las
mayores esponjas que consumen los gases
efecto invernadero que otros países
arrojan
la selva amazónica
las selvas de américa latina'
hoy se impone que colombia trate de
salvar la selva amazónica en función de
salvar la humanidad
nos han criticado
porque proponemos una transición
energética
quizás rauda dicen los críticos
hacia las energías limpias en las que
colombia tendría enormes ventajas
pues bien se trata de establecer ahora
un diálogo en las américas me han
llamado casi todos los presidentes de
américa latina'
[Aplausos]
y creo
que hoy si podemos proponer ahora sobre
este triunfo que nos ha dado el pueblo
colombiano
un diálogo en las américas sin
exclusiones de ningún pueblo de ninguna
nación
en toda la diversidad que es américa
yo creo que llegó el momento de
sentarnos con el gobierno de los eeuu
y hablar
dialogar
sobre lo que significa el hecho que en
todo este continente americano que
compartimos
allá se me está como casi ningún otro
país
gases efecto invernadero
y aquí los
asumimos los absorbemos a partir de
nuestra selva amazónica
si allá se emite y aquí absorbemos
porque no dialogamos
porque no establecemos
otra manera de entendernos
porque no dejar de emitir más allá y por
qué no ayudarnos aquí a que las esponjas
de la absorción de los gases de la
muerte de la humanidad puedan ser más
eficaces le propongo al gobierno de los
eeuu y a todos los gobiernos de américa
sentarnos a dialogar para acelerar los
pasos de la transición energética
los pasos de la construcción de una
economía descarbonizada
economía de la vida en toda américa como
un gobierno que pretende ser el gobierno
de la vida no podría proponer la
construcción de una economía de la vida
le propongo a américa latina
integrarnos más
decididamente
le propongo a colombia
mirarnos como
latinoamericanos que es lo que somos
no solo porque tengamos la sangre latina
sino también la afro
también la indígena ancestral
las razas que no es la palabra que hay
que usar ya
las corrientes étnicas que nos llevaron
a pensar que éramos el resumen cósmico
del planeta
américa latina'
que es también américa indígena que es
también américas afro que es también
américa anglosajona que es también
américas multicolor tiene que
encontrarse en el gran diálogo que
permita salvar a la humanidad al
progresismo de américa latina' le
propongo dejar de pensar la justicia
social
dejar de pensar la redistribución de la
riqueza dejar de pensar que es posible
un futuro
sustentado sobre la base de los altos
precios del petróleo del carbón o del
gas
porque es insostenible para la
existencia humana
a los progresismos de américa latina' le
propongo
pensar que américa latina puede
construirse alrededor de la agricultura
y las reformas agrarias de la
agroindustrialización
de la industria bajo las nuevas
tecnologías que todas significan la
producción sobre la base del
conocimiento y del reencuentro con la
naturaleza
una américa latina' productiva y nuestra
activista una américa latina que
profundice el conocimiento hasta las
máximas esferas del saber de la
humanidad una américa latina que gracias
a sus raíces negras e indígenas le pueda
proponer al mundo un verdadero
reequilibrio con la naturaleza para
poder vivir para poder existir una
américa latina' punta que le pueda
gritar a la humanidad que llegó el
momento de cambiar para poder vivir
para poder vivir sabroso
le agradezco
colombianas y colombianos
su apoyo
les agradezco
este día histórico
me lo soñaba de vez en cuando
me preguntaba si va a ser posible
[Aplausos]
estaré hablando el 19 como presidente de
la republica me preguntaba
[Aplausos]
aquí
somos una demostración
es que la paz es posible en colombia
de que los sueños se pueden volver
realidad los sueños de justicia los
sueños de igualdad los sueños de
libertad
decíamos en cartagena allá donde comenzó
con haití la libertad de américa que
volviéramos a gritar libertad
para gritemos libertad
libertad
para que no busca más
la masacre a negué el territorio
libertad para que nunca más un gobierno
asesine a sus jóvenes
libertad
para que nunca más
una política económica le quite la
comida al niño ya la niña
libertad para que los sueños puedan ser
para que una democracia aquí se pueda
construir para que una república sea
posible una democracia profunda
una democracia multicolor una democracia
de los hombres y de las mujeres libres
verdaderamente libres
que viva la libertad
que viva colombia
potencia mundial de la vida
me llamo
gustavo petro
y soy su presidente
[Música]
los quiero mucho
te quiero mucho colombia gracias
[Aplausos]